this video was made possible by
curiositystream
sign up for the holiday nebula bundle
deal for just 11.79 a year
at curiositystream.com forward slash
real engineering
to get ad-free access to our new podcast
modulus
if i was to ask you today what
technology breakthrough the world
needed most what would you say this
needs to be a technology we could
realistically develop
in the next 10 years so none of that
sci-fi nonsense
this is something i think about a lot
nuclear fusion or cheaper
safer and cleaner fission energy are
good candidates
human society would be transformed by
economic fusion power
but fusion is certainly not a technology
that we can commercialize
in the next 10 years many people are
working on safer
and cheaper nuclear fission but that too
has many hurdles to overcome
i think about how the world would change
if carbon nanotubes somehow became a
viable material
a new stronger and lighter material of
carbon nanotubes caliber
wouldn't open doors to new design
possibilities it would open portals to
new dimensions
but that again is not going to happen
anytime soon
no if i was to pick one technology that
would have the biggest impact on our
society today
that is within grasp it would be cheap
scalable
energy storage for the grid the
electricity grid works nearly entirely
on a just-in-time manufacturing method
we generate the electricity just as it's
needed there is no warehouse of
electricity that we can dip into
pumped hydroelectricity does provide
some storage
and is a nearly centuries-old technology
but
it's not scalable to our current needs
lithium-ion batteries
are our best option right now they have
proven their worth in the hornsdale
power reserve in australia
it was commissioned primarily as a fast
frequency response service
this means it can act as both the load
when the frequency of the grid gets too
high
or as a power source when the frequency
of the grid gets too low
kind of how a flywheel maintains the
rotational speed of an
engine you see our grids are designed to
operate on a particular alternating
current frequency
if the grid deviates from that frequency
it can cause
all kinds of issues that generally just
result in protective measures being
activated
to protect the infrastructure and
ultimately cuts power to its
users a blackout south australia was
struggling with these blackouts
in 2016 tornadoes ripped through south
australia
and damaged some power lines this caused
the voltage and frequency of the grid to
deviate
from its baseline this caused the wind
turbines to trip their protective
measures
and lower output now this was a massive
problem
because this is what south australia's
power generation looked like
on that day with nearly 50 percent of
their power coming from wind
to deal with the sudden decrease in
output in wind
the interconnector to victoria attempted
to increase its power transfer
but rather quickly shut itself down to
prevent the line frying itself
the grid basically did the technological
equivalent of a human
passing out when they see a drop of
blood a chain reaction of panic
leaving 850 000 people without power
in response the australian energy
regulator is trying to sue the wind
companies it had approved
for not doing a job they were not
capable of doing in frequency regulation
i feel like they only have themselves to
blame south australia had built far more
wind power than its grid could reliably
handle
it lacked the necessary interconnections
to neighboring grids
and energy storage facilities like
pumped hydro batteries or simply reserve
power
natural gas plants it was a poorly
planned grid
instability was inevitable we are
thankfully learning from these mistakes
but as renewables grow
the challenge of preventing blackouts
like this is only going to grow
we won't just need fast frequency
response but we will also need load
shifting
where we have enough storage to charge
batteries when renewables are available
and discharge them when it isn't this is
going to be expensive
lithium ion batteries are the cheapest
we have right now
but when it comes down to it they
weren't designed for this job
they are designed to be light and energy
dense for portable electronics
but for a stationary battery that's a
pretty useless trace to have
it's like having an underwater hair
dryer just doesn't make sense
lithium-ion batteries are the cheapest
form of energy storage available
because their mass-market adoption has
allowed for the economies of scale
to reduce their price but what if we
designed a new type of battery
a battery that was designed from the
ground up specifically for the grid
to learn more about this i spoke with
donald sadaway
a renowned professor of materials
chemistry at mit
and founder of liquid metal battery
company ambry
the last thing i do is seek the advice
of the incumbents
the incumbents are threatened by by in
radical innovation you realize that the
lithium-ion battery did not come from
the battery industry
the battery industry refused even
manufacture the lithium-ion battery
so sony sony wanted a better battery
to power their handheld device and this
is 1990
and sony goes to all of the big battery
producers in japan
and they go and they say here's the
here's the formulation
build this and here's a purchase order
for pick a number some tens of millions
of dollars
and each and every uh japanese
battery manufacturer said no my building
we have all of this capital investment
in the manufacture
of nickel metal hydride batteries
we can't build this battery in that
plant
and so they said no but somebody at some
point said
you know if we want to have lithium-ion
batteries for our appliances
there's only one way we're going to have
we're going to build them ourselves
and so sony says what had a battery
company it says
we need batteries and there's only one
way we're going to get them we're going
to build them ourselves and so sony
built the first
lithium-ion battery manufacturing
facility and very soon thereafter
they were getting inquiries from people
who are building mobile phones
saying can we have those and then people
who are building
mobile computers laptop computers can we
have those
and by 1995 nickel metal hybrid was
pretty much displaced
so what battery chemistry is professor
saturay trying to build
and can it have the same revolutionizing
disruptive effect on grid storage
that lithium-ion batteries had for
consumer electronics
the idea started simply professor
saturay had decades of experience in
electrolysis
for the refinement of metals like iron
and aluminium
that process takes a lot of energy to
refine the metal
so why not try to make that process
reversible
and allow the reverse reaction to give
electricity back
this is the basic concept of liquid
metal batteries we alloy
and de-alloy metals in a perfectly
reversible reaction they don't need to
be light
they need to be cheap and as professor
sataway says
i say if you want to make something dirt
cheap make it out of dirt
so how do we go about choosing materials
for a battery like this
what does the design ideation phase look
like professor sataway is a professor of
materials chemistry at mit
looking at a periodic table is a
different experience for him
this is what he sees when picking
materials for a technology
like this for the liquid metal battery
we first need to refine our search down
to metals
and metalloids which are these elements
next
we need to maximize the difference in
electronegativity
to maximize our voltage in general
electronegativity is highest on the top
right of the periodic table
and lowest on the lower left so our
electrode materials can be further
narrowed down
to elements in these two groups next
as professor sataway said if we want our
battery to be dirt cheap
we have to make it out of dirt so let's
plot our relative abundance of elements
of the candidate elements for our
negative electrode
calcium is by far the most common which
is the negative electrode of the ambry
liquid metal battery however they didn't
arrive at their current electrode
materials
just by analyzing the periodic table
experimentation was vital
as this is a complex and dynamic system
they have tested several combinations of
different electrode materials
from these two groups and there are a
lot of complicated interactions to
consider
ambry has landed on a calcium antimony
cell chemistry
so how does it work these materials are
placed into a ceramic
insulated cell together when a current
is applied the materials begin to heat
up
and eventually they will turn to liquid
and the metals will separate naturally
as a result of their density differences
the heavier positive electrode sinks to
the bottom with a neutral density
electrolyte
separating the lower density negative
electrode on top
this makes building the cell very simple
lithium ion batteries use complicated
coating processes to build their
electrodes
this is the charged state now when a
load is applied
the opposite electric current is
experienced this causes the calcium
electrode to break into a calcium cache
ion
and two electrons the cache ion travels
across the electrolyte bridge
and combines with the antimony and the
electrons that have traveled on the
external circuit
to form a new alloy this continues to
happen
until the calcium electrode is
completely consumed
now we just have the new mixed alloy and
the electrolyte
this is the discharge state to get back
to the charge state
we simply apply the opposite current and
the reverse reaction occurs
and creates a fresh battery now this
brings another advantage
lithium-ion batteries degrade over time
as they are charged and discharged
chemical reactions occur that damage the
electrodes and reduce their ability to
hold a charge
and many of the ways we need load
shifting batteries to operate
are the exact ways that accelerate this
degradation
over time taking a lithium ion battery
from full
to zero charge is particularly damaging
as few as
500 deep cycles can reduce the capacity
of the
nca batteries that tesla uses by as much
as 20
that represents about a year and four
months of daily use
for our load shifting batteries whose
job will be a daily one
however lfp batteries which tesla has
started using in its chinese model 3s
degrade much slower even under deep
cycling
and they have stated that they will use
lfp batteries
for stationary storage in the future
depending on the temperature they
operate at
lfp batteries drop to 85 to 95 percent
capacity
after 3 000 cycles higher temperatures
result in higher capacity drop
however ambry have shown that their
capacity fade is minimal
even after 5 000 cycles thanks to the
continual creation and destruction
of its electrodes allowing us to fully
discharge our batteries on a daily basis
for upwards of 20 years however as i'm
sure you have been wondering
keeping the calcium and antimony
electrodes so hot that they melt
comes with disadvantages for one we are
going to lose some of our electricity
to heating the materials up to
operational temperature
this reduces our round trip efficiency
so to explain it if you put 100 units of
electricity in
there are some losses because there's
some joule heating and so on and so
forth
with liquid metal battery it's about 80
percent
because the the difference the 20 is the
energy loss desirably to
heat the battery to keep it at
temperature so you say wow 80
that's 20 percent loss what's up with
that
the round-trip efficiency of pump hydro
is 70
so we're better than pumped hydro but
the
the thing is that this is a case of
don't don't answer irrelevant questions
because the the key question is what is
the
the cost of electricity so
this is where things get a little
complicated luckily we have an equation
to calculate the levelized cost of
electricity storage
it's determined by the total costs which
are the sum of the initial
capital costs the continual operation
and maintenance cost
the cost of charging and the end of life
costs
divided by the total electricity
discharged
based on ambry's calcium antimony cell
chemistry
the cost of electrode materials vastly
undercuts current
generation lithium-ion batteries with
the total cost of the liquid metal
battery electrode materials
coming in at 17 per kilowatt hour
versus 51.2 dollars per kilowatt hour
for the most common nickel manganese
cobalt batteries
if they manage to get the initial
capital cost down 66 percent
that decrease in round-trip efficiency
is a minor concern
these continual costs are hard to
predict operations and maintenance costs
for lithium-ion batteries could include
buying more batteries to bring total
capacity back in line
as the batteries fade we also have very
little data for
end-of-life costs which will primarily
be determined by how easily disposed of
or recyclable the batteries are for both
of these metrics
liquid metal batteries will likely have
an advantage
however even with the promise of liquid
metal batteries
lithium ion batteries have a major leg
up on
any potential competitor they have had
decades to work on the manufacturing
process and reduce their price
and they are still getting cheaper ambry
have proven the cell chemistry works
on the bench scale but actually bringing
a product to market
is much harder than proving the science
works
it's it's simply the the long journey
from lab bench to
marketplace we you know uh here at mit i
with
my team of students and postdocs we
worked on this i had a concept and
and then we reduced it to practice and
then
got it to the point where we said it's
time to start a company
now how do you take that and turn it
into a
marketable product that is uh
able to be manufactured you know at the
university
you know you make five cells and one of
them works and and you get a publication
out of it and everybody's high-fiving
and so on but
but in manufacturing you have to have
everything has to work so
so we had to design the manufacturing
process
and there's nobody to turn to there's no
there's no model
i can take the most brilliant the most
competent
people in the lithium ion battery
sector and almost everything that they
know
is inapplicable because they're the
lithium-ion
chemistry is different which means that
the format of the battery is different
their needs are different i mean they
have to guard against thermal rise
we have to guard against thermal fall
we want to keep our batteries hot
they're trying to prevent their
batteries from getting hot
there are dielectric hermetic seals that
have to survive
500 600 celsius so obviously they're
going to have to be ceramics
but ceramics are brittle fragile and
they don't like
thermal excursions but we have to be
able to
to endure thermal excursions
and i can give you a ceramic you can do
it like that but it's
going to cost something around a nasa
price point
designing an entirely novel product is
not easy those dielectric
hermetic seals in particular are a
tricky bit of engineering
they need to be dielectric to separate
the positive and negative electrodes
they need to form a seal to prevent
gases and moisture
from entering the battery and causing
corrosion and secondary reactions
it needs to be corrosive resistant as
those molten salt electrolytes can
corrode
many materials and to boot it needs to
be heat resistant
since the battery operates at 500
degrees celsius
those are four very specific
combinations of material properties
that don't come with an off-the-shelf
rubber o-ring
it's one thing to design a prototype
that works
but it's an entirely different beast to
design a product
that can be manufactured cost
effectively and reliably
when lithium-ion batteries first came to
market in the 90s
their price per kilowatt hour was
upwards of three thousand dollars
but over the past three decades that
price has continually dropped to about
150 dollars per kilowatt hour
there is no scenario where ambery comes
out of the gates
at this price point no matter how cheap
their electrode materials are
the price of a novel manufacturing
method will
offset any cost savings until the
economies of scale
take over this difficulty of bringing a
new technology to market
despite the obvious potential advantages
is called technological lock-in and it
makes it incredibly difficult for
newcomers to enter the market
if they can't compete with the cost
straight out of the gate
they are going to struggle to find
buyers in order for new products like
this to get to market
and start their journey to affordability
they often need to find a
niche market where their advantages
outweigh their costs
so where could liquid metal batteries
find this niche market
as we explained lithium-ion batteries
are temperature sensitive
without proper thermal management
lithium-ion batteries will
at best degrade faster but they can
also malfunction or even catch fire this
has already happened with a large-scale
lithium-ion battery in arizona where
battery degradation
led to a thermal runaway in other words
a rack of batteries failed
and caught fire leading to the shutdown
of
every battery storage facility in the
state
until the cause of the problem was found
these disadvantages of lithium-ion
batteries
are exactly what is going to open the
door for liquid metal
batteries the liquid metal battery can
work just fine
in extreme conditions after all the
entire product is designed to operate at
500 degrees
no cold or warm environment is going to
interfere
with its operation making the battery
better suited for hot weather climates
in an application where the batteries
need to operate in a warm climate
while being used daily and under deep
cycling
liquid metal batteries may be able to
justify their initial
high price point for the right early
adopter
and that's exactly what has happened
terascale
is a data center company that is
building a scalable data center
that will operate on its own renewable
micro grid
in the warm desert climate of reno
nevada it has already built
23 megawatts of geothermal and 10
megawatts of solar
as part of their phase 1 20 megawatt
data center
this will be attractive to companies
wanting to use green energy to run their
servers
and companies that want to shield their
data from potential power
outages or even cyber attacks through
grid vulnerabilities
which have become increasingly common
over the last decade
this microgrid will shield terrascale's
customers data
from such vulnerabilities but to run on
renewables
reliably they are going to need a lot of
energy storage
and for that they have turned to ambry
announcing
very recently that they will partner
with them
for a massive 250 megawatt hour battery
that will begin construction in 2021
enough storage to run the 20 megawatt
data center for 12 and a half hours
strays
this will be an excellent test of the
technology
and i for one will be following us
closely
because if it succeeds it's going to
revolutionize
how our grids operate forming that
missing link
of renewables we spoke with professor
satterway in far greater detail about
his work with liquid metal batteries
but it's difficult to squeeze all that
detail into a youtube video
that's why we started modulus a podcast
hosted by me
and stephanie from real science a
podcast
where we will dive into the people
behind the scientific stories we tell
here on youtube we will talk to the
scientists
who are on the cutting edge of research
and by the people who are affected by
the topics we discuss
we learn what it's like watching your
life's work descend onto the martian
surface
with babak for dowsie we get inside
information
with people like professor sataway
pioneering
revolutionary technology this podcast
will show
the real-life people behind these topics
and the real-life
impact these scientific stories have on
the world
the first episode of modulus launched on
nebula today
the streaming platform made by me and
several other
educational youtube content creators
it's
the place to watch our videos and
podcasts ad free
along with original content that is not
available anywhere else
like my logistics of d-day series or tom
scott's game show
money we can take more risks on nebula
where we don't have to worry about the
youtube algorithm
there is so much original content there
with more
being added all the time and to make it
even better
nebula has partnered with curiosity
curiositystream the streaming platform
with
thousands of high budget high quality
documentaries
like this one called the secret world of
lego that gives an inside look
into the world of lego's headquarters in
denmark if you've hesitated before to
get curiosity stream and nebula
and never quite pull the trigger now is
definitely the time to do it
for a limited time a yearly subscription
to the bundle deal
is on sale for just 11.79 per year
that's less than a dollar per month
signing up is also the best way to
support this channel
and all of your favorite educational
content creators
thanks for watching and if you'd like to
see more from me the links to my
instagram twitter and patreon are below
you